et de fidèles de ce club des territoires
bonjour Benjamin Morel merci beaucoup
d'être là et bonjour Yves très ah merci
d'être avec nous Quentin évidemment nous
a rejoint comme tous les vendre comme
tous les vendredis mais c'est le club du
lundi au vendredi
merci d'être là on va parler avec vous
des aller-retours du gouvernement sur le
projet de loi immigration finalement
Élisabeth borne souhaite une
présentation du texte en juillet on
conseille des ministres mais quel texte
le en même temps est-il vraiment
possible une majorité peut-elle se
dégager pour l'exécutif on verra ce que
vous en pensez puis à la fin de ce club
on vous emmène à Armentières dans le
Nord ou il célèbre brasserie renaît de
ses cendres vous verrez tout ça d'abord
on regarde l'actualité dans nos régions
on va en Loire-Atlantique parler de la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
retrouver Thomas H bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Thomas vous
êtes directeur départemental de la
Loire-Atlantique à Ouest français avec
vous évidemment on va revenir sur la
démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins après l'incendie
de son domicile après avoir subi des
menaces qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé
exactement Thomas
voilà alors Saint-Brevin c'est une
paisible station balnéaire 1 14.000
habitants en Loire-Atlantique au pied du
pont de Saint-Nazaire bordé par les
dunes de l'océan elle n'était pas
prédestinée à faire parler d'elle comme
hier dans un dans un grand mouvement
d'émotion nationale parce que c'est ce
qu'on a vécu hier quand même
c'est pourtant bien ce qui s'est tissé
si la préfixe depuis quelques mois avant
d'éclater mercredi soir avec la
démission du maire dans cette commune se
trouve un centre d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile qui doit déménager
près d'une école c'est un projet porté
par l'État et donc pas par le maire et
contre quelques riverains se sont élevés
et puis petit à petit au fil des
semaines le thon c'est en venimé
l'extrême droite a attisé le feu de la
colère et
sans que l'enquête de gendarmerie ne
sache encore le dire clairement si c'est
un lien direct la maison du maire a été
prise pour cible le 22 mars par un engin
incendiaire ou explosif dans son sommeil
il a marqué le coup il démissionne
effectivement vous nous l'avez un peu
dit il y a quand même un contexte dans
cette affaire Thomas quels sont les
ingrédients
alors en fait il y a trois ingrédients
dont on peut penser que il provoque
cette émotion très forte
d'abord il en a été question jusque
devant le Parlement européen hier elle
charrie trois sujets sensibles du moment
le premier c'est l'élu baching la mise
en cause des élus des élus de proximité
on observe depuis un peu plus d'un an un
nombre de démission absolument inédit de
conseiller municipaux de mer des élus
des pauses plaintes pour des menaces des
violences et souvent se plaignent de ne
pas être accompagné défendu par l'État
comme il fallait et c'est notamment le
cas dans l'affaire de Saint-Brevin mais
il est aussi question de laquelle des
étrangers évidemment et des demandeurs
d'asile particulièrement là encore se
posent des questions brûlantes
d'actualité comment les accueillir
sereinement dans ces conditions avec un
tel niveau de tension et de défiance
Akala qu'en centre Bretagne il y avait
un projet très similaire à celui de
Saint-Brévin et bien il a fallu faire
machine arrière et l'abandonner hier en
Loire-Atlantique le préfet a tout de
suite dit pas question ce projet
ira à son terme
est-ce que cette position pourront être
enfin il y a la question grandissante de
la présence des complexée d'une ultra
droite sur la voie publique ça a été le
cas à Saint-Brévin avec des prières de
rue avec des gens cagoulés masqués un
peu comme ce qu'on a vu à Paris et ce
que Gérard Dahmane Gérard Dammann le
ministre de l'Intérieur demande
désormais d'interdire et bien les
dernières à Saint-Brévin les deux
dernières manifestations avaient été
déclarées mais avait été déclaré par des
par des riverains opposés au projet pas
par un groupe d'ultra-droite le préfet
n'avait pas vu de raison de les
interdire elles ont pu être
instrumentalisées par des groupes très
véhément mais on voit bien qu'il y a ces
trois éléments qui se croisent dans
cette affaire et
ça n'a pas échappé au rassemblement
national qui a pris ses distances depuis
un moment qui est toujours en quête de
respectabilité et qui depuis deux mois a
vu que l'affaire tournait vraiment très
sombre à Saint-Brévin et c'était
désolidarisé des manifestations on
appelait plus à manifester et hier ils
ont été parmi les plus véléments pour
condamner
de faire parler de manœuvre de brutes
immorale qui vise à avoir gain de cause
je les cite par la terreur et la
brutalité au lieu de convaincre par la
raison voilà nous avons ces trois
ingrédients qui se jouent simultanément
et je pense que c'est c'est ce qui donne
à cette affaire
merci beaucoup merci Thomas d'avoir été
avec nous on suivra bien sûr cette
actualité avec vous mère de Saint-Brevin
la démission de trop c'est la Une de
Ouest-France aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
Thomas d'avoir été avec nous c'est la
démission de retour de trop Yves pour
vous
peut-être que ça sera la démission trop
mais j'irai un peu au-delà de ce qui
vient d'être dit parce que si vous
voulez c'est pas moi je pense que c'est
un climat de tension générale dans le
pays là il s'agit de l'extrême droite
mais vous avez aussi l'extrême gauche on
a pas oublié ça ne solide dès qu'il se
passe quelque chose dans notre pays
c'est un déchaînement de violence qui
est absolument inouï intolérable
inacceptable d'où qu'il vienne et
malheureusement c'est toujours le cas ça
c'est la première des choses la deuxième
chose c'est la le fait que l'État se
soit défaussé comment est-ce possible
que des projets qui sont aussi
importants que celui-ci et Dieu sait si
c'est important et c'est pas rien en
plus c'est pas un projet immobilier
c'est pas c'est plus que ça c'est il y a
des aussi des vies humaines dans cette
histoire avec des demandeurs d'asile qui
sont pas encore acceptées à l'asile
d'ailleurs il faut le signaler et ben
l'État devrait être beaucoup plus
regardant et de beaucoup plus présent ça
c'est la deuxième des choses la
troisième des choses c'est qu'il y a le
niveau de défiance aujourd'hui ça
manifeste aussi le niveau de défiance
qu'il y a vis-à-vis des élus et ce qui
est paradoxal c'est que les élus locaux
normalement dans tous les sondages se
sont eux qui sont les plus populaires
d'une certaine façon dans la population
et bien non ils sont aussi la cible de
d'attaque comme on le voit là donc moi
je crois qu'il faut pas si vous voulez
limiter ça un climat local oui il y a eu
des manifestations d'extrême droite mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va il faut qu'on arrête
aussi de de de ne rien dire contre ce
qui s'est passé à Sainte-Soline ce qui
s'est passé dans la ZAD de l'aéroport de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes enfin à chaque
fois maintenant qu'il y a un projet il y
a cette espèce de violence qui est une
violence qui ne correspond pas au
dialogue démocratique qu'est-ce que ça
dit de l'état de la société ce qui se
passe à Saint-Brevin Benjamin se dit
beaucoup de choses je rejoins évidemment
Yves sur énormément de points j'en
mettrai peut-être quatre en exerg déjà
il y a comme un kimal au calme c'est à
dire dans reste de la France on a
l'impression qu'il y fait bon vivre etc
vous avez des groupuscules d'extrême
droite et d'extrême gauche qui ont
toujours été extrêmement actifs et
derrière sous des regards derrière sous
des aspects très modérés de la vie
politique locale vous avez malgré tout
toujours eu cette permanence si on
accepte le kimal local il y a trois
éléments le premier élément c'est que
malgré tout il y a une ultra droite en
France et que c'est ultra droite elle
passe souvent sous les radars etc mais
elle était extrêmement structurée et
elle est malgré tout dangereuse quand
vous discutez avec les services de
renseignement je rappelle que le dernier
coup d'État crédible en Europe il vient
l'ultra-droite en Allemagne donc malgré
tout il y a quand même un risque et ce
risque-là il est moins visible que celui
de l'ultra gauche mais malgré tout il
doit être pris en considération deuxième
élément et bien on vit une période de
retour de la violence en politique c'est
pas si nouveau ce qu'on voit
actuellement on a l'impression que ça
n'est jamais arrivé et qu'on vit une
période exceptionnelle prenez le
poujadisme prenez les années 60 prenez
la Troisième République vous avez à
l'époque une violence politique
vis-à-vis des élus extrêmement forte
aujourd'hui se retourne la violence en
politique on ne connaît partout en
Europe vous avez un député qui a été
assassiné en Italie 2 en Grande-Bretagne
un président de l'Ender un président de
lande qui a été également assassiné je
crois en
makelembourg vapeur powerne en Allemagne
donc ce retour de la violence en
politique aujourd'hui il est présent la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on le
jugule quels sont les causes et le 3 et
le dernier élément qui est très très lié
et bien c'est qu'on a un retour de la
violence en politique mais sur un
terrain qui est déjà un terrain miné
pour les élus parce que quelle est la
vocation aujourd'hui des élus comment
est-ce qu'il se situe dans la société
comment est-ce qu'ils vivent leur mandat
qui plus est la plupart du temps quand
ils sont relativement méprisés et par
l'État et par leurs administrer etc
comment est-ce qu'ils arrivent à
supporter ça quand justement ils ont
l'impression de ne plus pouvoir et donc
évidemment quand vous avez ces deux
facteurs qui s'enchaînent et bien vous
avez un effet d'Exit vous avez un effet
d'émission et on peut comprendre les
élus qui donnent beaucoup de leur temps
et de leur énergie
l'inaction de l'État elle a été dénoncée
par beaucoup d'opposants politiques on
va justement voir les réactions qui ont
été nombreuses à cette démission
d'humeur avec Flora sauvage
après des mois d'intimidation et
l'incendie de sa maison en mars le maire
de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins a jeté l'éponge
sa démission fait suite aux violences
subies pour son soutien au projet de
transfert d'un centre d'hébergement pour
demandeurs d'asile près d'une école sa
ville a été le théâtre de manifestations
d'extrême droite après l'annonce de
l'arrivée de ce centre d'accueil dans sa
lettre de démission Yannick Morez mère
et médecin depuis 32 ans sur la commune
explique sa décision par le manque de
soutien de l'État à Saint-Brévin les
habitants sont choqués
ça ça donne l'impression que l'extrême
droite a gagné au plan national la
démission de Yannick Morez suscite une
vague d'indignation dans un message sur
Twitter le chef de l'État a exprimé sa
solidarité au maire des missionnaires
Marine Le Pen dénonce elle les
agressions à l'égard des élus j'ai
reconquête on accuse le gouvernement
d'instrumentaliser la décision du maire
on est en train d'utiliser ce fait très
problématique évidemment condamnable
pour en réalité culpabiliser l'opinion
qui s'opposerait à l'accueil de cession
de migrants
criminaliser donc les oppositions y
compris des oppositions légales et
démocratiques par des manifestations et
bâillonner l'opinion sous pression
l'exécutif tente de rassurer je voudrais
assurer le maire de tout mon soutien ça
montre qui a une montée de l'extrémisme
dans notre pays et évidemment il faut
qu'on soit très très vigilant au-delà du
territoire national la décision de
Yannick Forrez à des répercussions des
dizaines d'euros députés se sont levés
hier dans l'hémicycle du Parlement
européen en son honneur à gauche le PS
appelle à une marche le 24 mai en
soutien au maire démissionnaire Yannick
Morez sera auditionné le 17 mai par la
commission des Lois du Sénat
et on voit plusieurs élus plusieurs
opposants pointé une responsabilité de
l'extrême droite dans ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui au maire de Saint-Brévin
Yves oui certes mais l'extrême droite
elle a jamais disparu dans notre pays
elle a toujours été présente c'est vrai
ce que dit Benjamin elle est structurée
il y a des groupes d'accord mais on va
si on bon extraits gauche ça fait partie
de du débat politique et
la montée des extrêmes on la voit aussi
à l'Assemblée nationale je suis désolé
le spectacle donnait à l'Assemblée
nationale ne peut qu'encourager ou
décourager d'ailleurs c'est un double
tranchant ce qui se passe ailleurs que
dans que dans l'hémicycle on est dans
une société qui est extrêmement
fracturée avec des positions qui sont de
plus en plus radicales avec le sentiment
aussi que c'est par la violence
qu'aujourd'hui on se fait autant
entendre vous savez on est dans une
situation je sais plus qui a dit quand
on a plus rien à dire mais on tape ben
on est dans une société comme ça
c'est-à-dire que les gens n'ont pas
d'arguments sans argument
c'est une façon de d'envisager le débat
qui est tout à fait détestable et qui à
qui et qui ne fait pas grandir je dirais
la démocratie mais bon je moi je veux
pas être négatif et je veux pas être
pessimiste je pense qu'il y a des moyens
pour faire en sorte que le justement
tout ça recule je pense que c'est aussi
une grande responsabilité de la du
personnel politique de reprendre ces
je dirais
la conscience de sa responsabilité et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup
parmi les députés parmi les sénateurs
qui attisent et qui mettent le feu se
sont eux les responsables aussi dans un
une famille politique particulière dans
toutes les familles politiques il suffit
de les voir ce comporter à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pas nouveau comme le
disait Benjamin évidemment que ça a
toujours existé sauf qu'il y avait du
talent dans le temps aujourd'hui c'est
pas du talent c'est de la vulgarité
sur ce point là en effet on n'a pas le
Parlement je dirais le on n'a pas le
Parlement le plus élevé depuis la
fondation de la 5e République néanmo il
y a des facteurs structuraux comme je
l'ai évoqué aujourd'hui c'est toutes les
démocraties occidentales qui sont
touchées il faut bien faire attention
quand on parle ici d'extrême droite
c'est pas pour dire le RN c'est
différent etc mais si justement là on
est vraiment face à des groupuscules qui
sont des groupuscules excusez-moi le
terme mais un peu nazis et ces
groupuscules il perdurent quel que soit
le résultat électoraux parce qu'en
réalité leur stratégie n'est pas
électorale leur stratégie c'est
justement de faire la révolution dans
une perspective qui est une perspective
la d'ultra droite réellement nationale
révolutionnaire donc on est face à des
groupuscules qui malgré tout son
dangereux parce qu'ils ont une stratégie
du coup et qu'ils utilisent et bien des
moments des outils des phénomènes et des
faits comme ceux auxquels on assiste ici
pour justement bien faire valoir leurs
causes recruter etc ainsi ils sont assez
proches des stratégies de l'ultra gauche
qu'on a vu avec les Black Blocs etc et
un dernier point que j'aimerais aborder
rapidement
c'est quand même la question qui était
évoqué un peu parive mais l'aménagement
du territoire et la façon dont on
conçoit aujourd'hui l'intérêt national
on est aujourd'hui que ce soit sur les
sujets d'autoroute sur les sujets
d'immigration etc face au même les
sujets de prison on a abordé il y a peu
de temps et ben face à d'un côté des
populations et de l'autre parfois des
élus qui bloquent les projets
considérant que là on n'en veut pas que
là il y a un intérêt local qui doit
primer sur l'intérêt national si on
avait fait ça dans les années 60 on
aurait aujourd'hui un pays qui n'aurait
absolument aucune infrastructure donc il
est nécessaire aujourd'hui de repenser
entre guillemets nation de repenser
également aménagement et de repenser
primauté de l'intérêt général pour ça il
faut avoir un projet politique et là où
je rejoins totalement Yves c'est que le
personnel politique et bien aujourd'hui
n'a visiblement pas le niveau pour se
projeter dans un projet politique ce qui
explique également localement beaucoup
de résistance et vous évoquez la
question de l'immigration on va parler
du texte avec vous Quentin dans quelques
instants parce que les tensions dans
cette commune de Loire-Atlantique on le
rappelle elles sont parties de la
question d'un transfert de centre
d'accueil des demande urs d'asile
oui alors il y a un transfert d'accueil
qui a été qui était décidé par l'État
d'ailleurs parce que il semblerait
d'après mes informations mais que le
centre d'accueil qui existait a été trop
trop exiguë pour le nombre de migrants
parce que la France reçoit de plus en
plus de migrants l'immigration est un
vrai sujet un sujet qu'il faut pas c'est
pas une des priorités si j'ai bien
compris dans les sondages qui sont faits
auprès de l'opinion c'est pas par
rapport au pouvoir d'achat à l'inflation
c'est pas une une préoccupation de
premier plan mais ça existe et comme le
dit Benjamin il faut anticiper parce
qu'après ça éclate et c'est à ce moment
là qu'on se réveille et qu'on dit il
faut anticiper et effectivement c'était
le sujet et là ça serait intéressant
d'avoir un débat justement sur
l'immigration ce sera intéressant
d'avoir un débat sur ce projet de loi
que veut nous présenter le président de
la République et sa première sa première
ministre ça ça reste ça démontré mais
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il soit sur la
même longueur d'onde si vous voulez
Fiona qui qui semble pointer d'urgence
qui s'appelle le président de la
République et une autre qui dit bon
c'est peut-être pas le moment le pays
est tellement sur un volcan que il faut
peut-être pas
attiser les les les braises mais c'est
un c'est un vrai sujet et d'ailleurs si
vous regardez bien les les études
d'opinion qui sont faites même à gauche
le sujet de l'immigration est un sujet
qui doit être traité
et peut-être que les les difficultés
relation on va dire entre Isabelle bande
et Emmanuel Macron explique les nombreux
rebondissements qui a eu sur le projet
de l'immigration
effectivement ouais il sera bien
présenté donc en conseil des ministres
en juillet ce projet immigration c'est
l'information que vous avez révélé cette
semaine au Figaro mais le 26 avril la
première ministre parce qu'elle avait
présenté ça a failli de route pour les
100 jours elle avait pourtant acté et
qu'il n'y avait pas de majorité pour
voter un seul texte dixit et c'est alors
déjà le deuxième report de ce projet de
loi immigration et alors qu'il semble
loin l'article du Monde du 2 novembre
2022 de la présentation de ce projet de
loi immigration rappelez-vous un texte
porté à la fois par Gérald darmann et
Olivier du soft pour l'équilibre entre
le répressif et l'intégration par le
travail mais donc le texte sera bien
finalement au programme d'ici la césure
estivale en tout cas il sera présenté en
Conseil des ministres en juillet et on
sait qu'il y aura pas de session
parlementaire en septembre pour cause
d'élections c'est naturel ça renvoie
donc l'examen à octobre prochain c'est
ce que vous avez donc révélé au Figaro
géraldar maintenant a ainsi été chargé
par Isabelle borne de reprendre des
consultations pendant un mois pour
proposer je cite une stratégie
permettant de faire adopter des mesures
efficaces et pouvoir rassembler la
majorité présidentielle alors comment
faut-il comprendre ce nouveau
revermement ici au Sénat les LR bien sûr
ironise écoutez leur chef de fil Bruno
Retailleau au micro publics
public il y a quelques semaines avaient
annoncé qu'il y aura un texte l'été
ensuite qui serait sauditionné et
maintenant nous annonce à nouveau un
texte on s'y retrouve plus c'est quelque
chose qui tient je trouve du gag
les LR qui avait déposé deux
propositions de loi sur le sujet la
première ordinaire sur la refonte de
l'aide médicale d'État par exemple en
aide médicale d'urgence quelque chose
qu'il va être régulièrement notamment au
Sénat et LR c'est donc pour les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
l'autre l'autre texte pour changer la
constitution et proposer un référendum
sur l'immigration et c'est sans doute
cette actualité parlementaire venue de
la droite parlementaire qui a causé ce
revirement du gouvernement
dans ce texte présentant en juillet du
coup non
c'est vrai autant le texte précédent
celui qui a été reporté il avait déjà
passé l'étape du Conseil des ministres
et il avait dépassé il est aussi l'étape
de la commission des Lois du Sénat il
était prêt à être examiné en séance
publique au Sénat mais donc le
gouvernement on comprend il fait table
rase de ce texte écoutez Olivier Véran
mercredi à la sortie du Conseil des
ministres
pour répondre à votre question s'il y a
un nouveau projet de loi qui sera
présenté en juillet c'est que à ce stade
il n'a pas été présenté donc je serais
bien en peine de vous dire si ce sera le
même projet ou presque le même projet ou
un projet qui aura été modifié ou
transformé à l'écoute des forces
politiques de notre pays une chose est
sûre c'est qu'une ne sera pas donc
examiné en juillet et mais donc plutôt
en octobre après les élections
sénatoriales donc près d'un an du moment
que sa présentation est-ce que le texte
peut être fait être identique Benjamin
là on le rappelle c'était un texte avec
une jambe droite une jambe gauche pour
contenter un peu tout le monde est-ce
que le en même temps est tenable on
verra au bout du compte pour l'instant
le contenu du texte et en effet assez
peu assez peu posé non je dirais qu'il y
a deux arguments pour et deux arguments
pour compte pour le pour le gouvernement
et pour l'Élysée sur les arguments pour
on a d'abord une façon de mettre en
porte-à-faux LR ah vous voulez pas nous
soutenir mais regardez on a un taxe sur
l'immigration ensuite ça arrive au mois
de juillet en conseil des ministres et
c'est pas tout à fait notre non plus
parce qu'en réalité si vous prononcez le
mot 49 alinéa 3 lors d'un conseil des
ministres du le mois de juillet il
compte pour votre session extraordinaire
évidemment là je parle un peu chinois
mais il faut bien comprendre que du coup
ça vous fait un 49 à une 3 gratuit pour
votre session ordinaire suivantes c'est
de l'argustine constitutionnalisme mais
quand on voit qu'ils ne l'ont pas fait
l'année dernière et tout ce que ça
entraînait ensuite comme conséquence on
voit qu'ils arrivent un peu à prendre de
leurs erreurs au moins procéduralement
ensuite les deux arguments contre et ils
sont quand même majeurs c'est pour ça
qu'on peut entendre Elisabeth borne qui
est visiblement dans ce couple exécutif
ne s'entend pas très très bien avec
Emmanuel Macron mais ça va diviser la
majorité il y a déjà ça sur Willy qui
dit qu'il veut te rappe un texte avec LR
donc forcément aujourd'hui au vu du
caractère extrêmement compliqué à gérer
de cette majorité pas sûr que soit une
bonne idée faut pas oublier que lors de
la dernière législature le premier texte
qui met le faux poudre au sein de la
majorité précédente pléthory car
relativement Unis c'est le texte asile
et immigration pure à Colomb donc c'est
vraiment un facteur de tension alors
certes la gauche de la majorité moins
nombreuse que j’adisse mais malgré tout
aujourd'hui elle est d'autant plus
essentielle l'autre élément qui peut
être problématique et ben c'est que
forcément avec ce texte là vous avez
malgré tout et bien des éléments qui
vont être des éléments qui vont conduire
probablement potentiellement à utiliser
le 49 alinatoires il est certes borne
qui est de plus alors est-ce qu'elle
sera là en octobre ça c'est un autre
sujet mais je laisserai faire des
prédictions sur le sujet mais au vu de
la politisation aujourd'hui cet
instrument et ben l'utiliser risque de
mettre sur ce sujet comme sur un autre
le feu aux poudres et surtout au sein de
sa majorité il fait ce que c'est ce que
disent les républicains ils disent mais
c'est pas chez nous qui a des divisions
sur le sujet de l'immigration c'est au
sein de la majorité présidentielle oui
bien sûr il y a des divisions par
définition c'est une majorité composites
avec des gens qui ont plutôt une
sensibilité de gauche d'autres qui ont
plutôt une sensibilité de droite d'où
justement cette ce travail de tapisserie
avec
des mesures qui peuvent contenter les
uns et d'autres qui peuvent contempler
les autres on va voir moi je finis par
penser que ça va être l'arlésienne de du
quinquennat ou du mandat c'est à dire
que il va rien se passer du tout
peut-être
parce que ça risque de déboucher et je
crois que le gouvernement ne veut pas se
permettre une deuxième crise comme celle
qu'il a traversé avec les retraites donc
très compliqué parce que est-ce qu'il
peut est-ce qu'ils peuvent trouver une
majorité il faudrait pour que ça passe
que il faisait
leur majorité au complet ils ne sont pas
divisés et que s'ajoutent à cette
majorité là une grosse partie des
républicains ça paraît quand même assez
mal parti parce que en plus les
républicains ne veulent pas leur faire
ce cadeau justement ils veulent montrer
leur désaccords vis-à-vis du parti du
texte si le texte encore une fois et le
même que celui qui a été imaginé avant
avant que qu'il soit mis de côté donc ça
me paraît quand même assez compliqué
surtout de faire ça alors qu'il y a
d'autres urgences les urgences sur
économiques pour lesquels le
gouvernement s'y prend plutôt pas mal
d'ailleurs un mot Quentin oui ça donne
aussi le sentiment c'est revirements sur
la date de présentation du texte qui est
aussi peut-être de la friture sur la
ligne entre Elisabeth borne et son
ministre Darmanin c'est en tout cas le
sentiment de sénateur qui qui ont relevé
aussi que Gérald Darmanin n'était pas à
la Réunion alors que dans son
portefeuille il y a les outre-mer et
pour eux c'est le signe que en ce moment
ce serait compliqué avec Emmanuel Macron
qui aurait tranché en faveur de Gérald
Darmanin pour que le texte soit bien
présenté là où effectivement ce qu'on
disait Isabelle bande serait peut-être
plus réticents de politiquement
avec Emmanuel Macron du coup Géral là
maintenant pour vous ce texte pour aller
au bout Benjamin il nous reste 30
secondes franchement c'est compliqué
franchement sauf 49 alinéa 3
actuellement pour les raisons cadies je
ne le vois pas arriver au bout il y a
pas de majorité et qui plus est il y a
pas de volonté ni de la gauche de la
majorité ni de LR de faire un cadeau à
Gérald Darmanin donc un avenir bien
obscur et on suivra tout ça on aura
évidemment l'occasion d'en parler le
vendredi Benjamin le sait Yves peut-être
un
peu moins on va voir les traditions de
nos régions les personnalités de nos
régions
[Rires]
il y a 4 ans les héritiers de la famille
mode cordonnier ont décidé de relancer
l'entreprise revendue en 1970 on regarde
fabriquer de la bière c'est être un peu
chimiste être précis et avoir du goût
c'est la levure qu'on sort un effet
c'est l'excédent de levure qu'on va
qu'on va jeter tout bêtement parce que
sinon ça va faire du trouble dans une
bonne bière
[Musique]
cette bière c'est la Renée le produit
phare de la brasserie Motte cordonnier
prenez son arrière arrière-grand-père
qui a construit la brasserie Le Château
usine le long de la Lys après la
Première Guerre mondiale suite on a la
Émile qui est le triple à 9 degrés une
bonne bière de dégustation
[Musique]
de ceux qui ont fait l'histoire de la
brasserie c'est une histoire d'homme
d'humain des gens qui ont travaillé dans
la brasserie qui sont dévoués etc un peu
comme aujourd'hui on est 8 on est là
tous les jours à s'entraider à
travailler et donc c'est important pour
nous de raconter cette histoire à
travers les personnages qui ont vécu
cette histoire cette histoire c'est
celle d'une brasserie qui fut la plus
importante du Nord de la France
basé à Armentières elle est restée dans
la famille mode cordonnier pendant 8
générations jusqu'en 1970 elle est alors
rachetée par un géant du secteur qui va
peu à peu abandonner le site mais en
2019 les héritiers décident de relancer
l'aventure c'est le film mon grand-père
nous quitte c'était la 8e génération de
brasseur avec lui s'arrête un peu le fil
rouge des générations et donc on s'est
dit bah c'est quand même dommage cette
histoire s'arrête là et on a eu
l'opportunité avec le marché qui se
relance mais aussi de récupérer le nom
en mode cordonnier pour se leur relancer
de 0 et voilà on va réinventer la
brasserie moteur donné du 20e siècle
fini les bières industriels de l'époque
de son grand-père aujourd'hui
l'entreprise vise le marché artisanal
avec mon téléphone je vais réussir en
fait à mesurer la densité la teneur en
sucre de ma bière et donc s'assurer que
ben en fait les levures et bien
travaillées et que la bière ne va pas
refaire monter au sein du fût avant de
prendre les reines de l'entreprise
familiale Henri Motte a délaissé sa
carrière d'ingénieur pour apprendre le
métier auprès d'un brasseur
professionnel vous voulez me former ou
pour comprendre un petit peu quels
étaient les leviers pour justement
produire une bière de qualité là on est
vraiment dans un souhait de travailler
sur la qualité sur l'artisanat et donc
c'était primordial pour moi de bien
comprendre le process de A à Z une fois
les contrôles effectués la Renée est
prête pour la mise en fût aujourd'hui
assuré par Clément apprenti brasseur je
suis originaire d'Armentières à la base
donc ça me tenait à coeur de venir
travailler chez Mode cordonnier pour
faire perdurer finalement ce patrimoine
brassicole
et aussi parce que le l'ambiance
familiale est a été conservée si je puis
dire on est une petite entreprise de
moins de 10 salariés donc c'est vrai que
l'ambiance qui règne et est agréable
pour travailler quoi
contre mille à l'âge d'or de
l'entreprise
vendus dans tous les hauts de France
avec une croissance du chiffre
d'affaires de 40% par an elle vise
désormais le marché parisien donc quand
un verdict parce que vous vous l'avez
goûté
artisanale mais elle est très légère et
très bonne voilà
je vous en aimerais
bien
on va regarder ce qu'elle a une de la
presse régionale
[Musique]
et quand on a la presse régionale
revient sur la décision du maire de
Saint-Brévin voilà effectivement on en
parlait dans cette émission la
déflagration d'une démissionuit-on par
exemple à la Une de Presse Océan le
journal de Nantes on l'avait vu tout à
l'heure à Ouest-France qui parle d'une
démission de trop le télégramme qui
parle d'une ville sous le choc mais les
habitants qui comprennent en fait la
décision les temps dans le journal ce
maire psychologiquement a pris très cher
raconte ses administrés les habitants
dans le journal qui raconte les
rassemblements d'extrême droite c'était
presque devenu un sport avec des gens
qui devenaient pas de Saint-Brevin
raconte les Brévinois qui interrogés
dans le journal raconte également une
cohabitation avec les demandeurs d'asile
qui se passaient plutôt bien tout le
monde qui regrette qu'il faille en
arriver là pour que le maire soit
soutenu lamentable la Chine habitante de
la commune c'est une autre mère qui fait
la ligne de Sud-Ouest ce matin elle rend
son écharpe à Macron cet élu d'une
commune de Gironde adresse une longue
lettre ouverte à Emmanuel Macron avec
Catherine vessie se dit solidaire de la
décision de Yannick Morez et raconte un
délitement de la relation de l'État avec
les mères et l'évoque la relation qui se
détériore entre les mers et les
habitants conséquence selon elle d'un
renforcement de l'individualisme et
d'une fonction de moins en moins
respectée la Voix du Nord titre sur la
rien du streetisation en marche
effectivement le président de la
République qui sera aujourd'hui à
Dunkerque la sous-préfecture du Nord le
journal fait le bilan sur le niveau de
l'industrie dans les Hauts-de-France la
région a perdu 41000 postes ces 10
dernières années avec 270
000 postes en 2022 mais une nouvelle ère
s'ouvre pour la région avec 16 à 20 000
emplois à créer attendu à Dunkerque dans
les 10 prochaines années la sécheresse
continue de faire la une de la presse
régionale bien sûr pas un jour sans un
titre de la PQR sur la sécheresse en
France ici en Côte-d'Or ou en note un
manque d'eau également les périnée
orientales ont déjà interdit la vente
des piscines ça lance un débat jusqu'à à
Dijon on va tant en arriver là se
demande la population allez c'est
vendredi on termine avec un sujet plus
léger
20 elle a une de lionne républicaine
avant le 20 la plante zoom cette famille
qui produit des plans de vigne pour la
Bourgogne depuis 4 générations l'étape
est très importante en ce moment et
beaucoup de travail elle a pépinièreiste
viticole les pépiniéristes viticoles
c'est le premier maillot de la
construction d'un vin dans les
territoires
merci Quentin vous avez encore des
choses je m'attendais merci beaucoup
Quentin pour cette revue de presse on
regarde la nuit figaroïne d'être déficit
les promesses antonables de la France
oui alors bon moi ça c'est un vieux une
vieille ritournelle aussi la France n'a
pas voté un budget à l'équilibre depuis
1974 c'était le président Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing donc vous voyez un petit peu
on est à des pays qui dépensent le plus
la dépense publique est très forte ce
qui peut s'expliquer par nos services
publics malheureusement les services
publics sont de moins bonne qualité que
par le passé et on arrive jamais à faire
des économies en début des promesses de
tous les candidats qui sont de gauche
droite à l'élection présidentielle et
c'est à dire dans le Figaro merci
beaucoup Yves à lundi merci Benjamin à
lundi peut-être aussi vous nous le direz
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis pour
voir au revoir cette émission notre
nouvelle plateforme public sénat.fr on
vous souhaite un excellent weekend à
lundi
[Musique]